well i don't know if you uh have heard
about this but something really is
really popular these days with the kids
are uh video games
a lot of kids play the video games and
even more than that they uh apparently
the kids will also sit and watch other
people play video games
on the internet
i want to judge you for that if you do
that but then again i will sit and watch
a youtube video of somebody bass fishing
for two and a half hours look at cody's
face show them the belly on that thing
yeah get my dang spanking too they've
been a little naughty today so i guess i
can't really judge too much so today i'm
going to play a video game
and i guess offer my review of it or
something
last video game system i owned was
and the last one i played was super
nintendo i was a big super mario
brothers fan super mario world rather
we're gonna give this a shot this is um
what is this that i'm playing this is
call of duty
it's a call of duty modern warfare
call of duty modern warfare is what this
is
and we'll uh i've literally never played
a game like this in my entire life but
we will i don't even know how to start
it they gave me the quick tutorial and i
already forgot how to how do i start it
so you're going to push the x button to
begin the game okay
x
all right we're in london
what's the mission can i skip past all
the i don't care about the story i just
want to get i want to get into shooting
people that's the main thing i'm into
here
it's only about a 20-second cutscene and
then you'll get to the action
okay but i'm still bored
looks like we're on our own lads
we'll handle it let's get it done yeah
hey firm
sergeant yeah these graphics are pretty
impressive i gotta say these are pretty
fancy graphics
that that is the level of uh of a review
you're gonna get from me these are some
fancy graphics
all right
left side so let's first of all not
seeing any coins to collect
are there any like mushrooms that will
make me grow tall or help me fly
not in war how do i shoot
you broke the rules of engagement don't
shoot first what what is the fun of a
video game where you can't shoot first
we're letting out our violent fantasies
so we
cause so we don't do it in real life
isn't that the whole point
oh god i just stabbed a parking
attendant
where's the button to turn myself in
what's happening right now
okay
am i going away i just oh
can i jump on them and make them
disappear
how do i jump
x the x button
but if i jump that won't do anything
i don't know what's happening right
first of all this is can i just say
something before we continue the
graphics are impressive
very fancy very real looking
but isn't the whole you know for me
going back to my childhood
playing super mario world
you know you're you're in this cart
you're in you're in basically someone
else's lsd
hallucination and i thought that was
sort of the point so what's what's the
if i want to be in reality then
if i want to be in an environment that
looks like a
a street i'll just go out to the street
well this looks almost like the real
world well it's the real world's right
here i you know what i could just look
away from the tv and look over here whoa
those are good graphics
so i don't know there's almost too much
realism for me it's like i can touch you
okay how do i switch my uh weapon to get
something a little bit more
uh if you go over to a gun on the ground
and push square
a gun on the ground okay where's the gun
on the ground walk the opposite
direction i it's it's i'm turning around
way too fast
oh right there
now i wanted like a bazooka or something
do i have like a machine gun or let's
get let's get going here let's start
shooting some people
oh
so there's been a terrorist attack in
london
and now
we're going out to kill the terrorists
my team has deserted me there
you're walking away from the action wait
how do i get back to
i didn't
i wanted to go around the corner and cut
them out cut off the bad guys on the
other side this big brain time all right
so
well maybe the civilian should get out
of the freaking way what are you doing
running through live fire you morons
well get down get behind a car or
something get get down go
i didn't even shoot that guy i didn't
shoot him
[Music]
okay i did shoot that guy
[Music]
you know what this is their fault i'm
i'm just
firing
got this guy
[Music]
that's your teammate oh
all right i'll get back to that
[Music]
wait a second i'm shooting the sky
[Music]
so how how am i doing so far pretty
poorly
a good soldier if i've ever seen one
i i can tell you right now um i'm not a
video game fan
because you know somewhat infamously you
know there's kind of a story behind that
sort of a traumatic story this is
actually my my maybe my super
my super villain origin story because i
wanted nintendo 64 for christmas in 64
rules
and i was told by my parents oh yeah
we'll get you nintendo for christmas and
so i was bragging about it i'm gonna get
n64 for christmas
and then christmas comes and all my
friends get n64 and i got uh super
nintendo
and then i went to school the next day
and everyone was talking about their
n64s and i don't want to be embarrassed
so i lied and said that i got n64 too
and they were asking me oh what kind of
games did you play what kind of games oh
you know yeah that's the normal ones and
it was this whole web of lies until
finally it was exposed when some friends
came over and saw that i only had a
super nintendo anyway the point is
maybe that's the reason why i've always
hated video games and i don't play them
now
or
it's possible i don't play them now
because i'm uh what do you call it a
grown-up i'm a grown-ass man and that's
really the main thing all right i'll try
one more time
what what's the objective i kill the
terrorists and then
just to stay alive
my objective now is just to survive for
more than 30 seconds
all right i feel pretty safe here
apparently not
stuck behind this plant here oh
he's right there
i got him right in the crotch do i i
don't get extra lives or do i get isn't
that a video game thing i'm just going
to keep going
i'm charging into a line of fire
taking fire but it's all right
this is courage right now on my part
courageous soldier is a dead soldier as
they say
and there i go
i think i did pretty well all things
considered
[Music]
if
for some
ungodly reason you enjoyed the content
that you just saw or even if you didn't
i would still appreciate it if you would
hit like and subscribe and do it right
now so i don't have to yell at you